so this is Sal Khan here of the Khan
Academy you know we're gonna do a really
fun experiment this morning we're on
Google Hangouts on air with with
secretary Duncan Secretary Arne Duncan
the Secretary of Education and we're
just gonna have a conversation about
technology about education about higher
education and I'll just hand it over
secretary Duncan well I hand it back to
you and take any questions you have but
just as you know I'm a big fan of your
work my children have really enjoyed
participating in Khan Academy lots of
exciting things going on obviously came
off the bus tour last night with the
president we're really working hard to
reduce college costs but what is talking
about college costs or technology or k12
or four more trying to more early
childhood happy to take any questions
you have and again thanks so much for
the leadership and the extraordinary
amount of opportunity you're creating
for children not just in this country
but across the globe it's pretty amazing
to see Oh No thank you that means a lot
to have to hear from from you and your
children who's kind of Canada they do
use Khan Academy Norsemen you actually
enjoyed it I don't have to beat them and
make them do it
I may even enjoy it that's great
fantastic so the place I really want to
start on him you get a lot of comments
here especially because a lot of the
news with the bus tour that you all have
been making around some of the
announcements around trying to reduce a
college education cost we got on
Facebook and on Twitter from Science Guy
what element of the reform plan do you
think is going to be the biggest change
the biggest game-changer and then
Hussein Mirza and June Kendall they're
all asking around this how do you how
are you going to address the the cost
issue with this plan and and and do you
think it's actually going to happen
there it seemed like there was some
resistance from at least comments from
from members of Congress there's always
gonna be resistance and change as hard
as you know but let me just start with
sort of explaining the problem I have to
tell you virtually everywhere I go
whether it's to the grocery store or
whether so the dry cleaners every plane
out I'm on you have hardworking
middle-class parents coming up and it's
almost heartbreaking basically pleading
for help and college costs are just
crushing folks and when you polled the
American public it's pretty scary a lot
of people starting to think that college
isn't for
it's for the wealthiest for the richest
for people not like them and so at a
time and going to college has never been
more important unfortunately ever been
more expensive and so we have to work
together to drive down cost we have to
have much greater transparency and help
young people and their families make
better choices we have to challenge
States to continue to invest we can't do
it by ourselves we have to make sure
that young people have a set of good
options to select from and know what a
loan is what's a grant what a graduation
rates what are the particular strengths
or weaknesses of majors at different
places but to see the president so
engaged is fantastic and this is one
simply where we have to break through
and this should not be political we want
to lead the world in college graduation
rates right now we're on a path in terms
of escalating cost that is unsustainable
so having a honest conversation with a
public how do we better encourage States
to do the right thing how do we better
rank universities and rate them based
upon are they taking in low-income
students are they graduating are they
keeping down college cost there should
be nothing political about any of this I
look forward to working with uh not just
the public but with members of your
Republicans and Democrats in the House
and Senate to do the right thing for our
country this to me again is not just
about helping individual and their
families we're really fighting for our
country's economic future and to remain
economically competitive we need to have
the best educated workforce in the world
in some form of higher education has to
be the goal for every single young
person a high school diploma is no
longer enough so four-year universities
two-year community colleges trade
technical vocational training that has
to be the goal for everyone
and families have to have the security
that they get if they work hard doesn't
have a chance to pursue that goal that's
what this is about
and and this is a kind of an overarching
theme of this plan especially around the
rankings is to ranks to rank
universities based on essentially value
that they create or the economic
opportunities for the students
afterwards and so that the universities
that are really expensive and the
students aren't getting good jobs
afterwards they're going to be at the
kind of the bottom of the list and might
not get a grant funding or subsidized
loans
well we're opening all this and want to
have a really public conversation over
the next year and get the best ideas and
I'm always interested in our
universities improving as their growth
and gain so our graduate
rates going up or down or are they
stagnant are they serving more
low-income and first-generation Pell
Grant recipients are graduates being
able to compete successfully in job
market afterwards but there's a whole
host of things I'm very aware that if
you put the wrong metrics out there you
can create some perverse incentives and
disincentives and encourage bad behavior
that's obviously the last thing you undo
and we're going to be very thoughtful
and nuanced and so no preconceived
notions we're going to go out and talk
to your professors and presidents and
parents and students themselves have a
national conversation at the back end of
that come up with something that makes
more sense what many folks don't
understand is today we invest about a
hundred and fifty billion dollars each
year in grants and loans it's a huge
investment that we make happily in the
taxpayer support but all of that
investment sau is based upon inputs
access to college none of it is on
outcomes our students actually
graduating are they graduating with
skills will help them be successful the
rest of their life and so having a
greater emphasis not just on access
which is important but really on the
outcomes that's where we want to go
makes sense makes sense and with that I
mean with some of the the statements
that you open y'all have been making you
know we got a lot of tweets you know
this is from Becky bacala we all talk a
lot about also the importance of
technology and education and how
technology might be a tool to to
increase accessibility but it did it did
raise some concerns from from several
folks Becky bacala wrote some students
only chance of caring human interactions
are school wise online learning better
Erica Kirchner wrote for placing
teachers with computers to save money on
these short changes our kids also wrote
the technology must work in concert with
the teacher it's not the teacher so so
what are your thoughts ed there's a lot
of fear around when people talk about
technology and especially when they're
talking about it in the context of cost
savings that it means that you're gonna
you're gonna have fewer human beings
involved yeah I always think these false
dichotomies false debates technology is
never gonna replace great teachers and
what all the research all the studies
seem to show is that blended learning
great teachers empowered by great
technology is what's leading to the best
educational outcomes achievement for
students and as I you know travel the
country and get to go to hundreds of
schools each year which I love I'm
seeing amazing teachers some you know
young teachers some 25 to 30 year
veteran teachers who talk very openly
with me about their initial apprehension
and fear about using technology in
classroom but how much more empowered
they feel how much more effective they
feel how much more engaged their
students are in their learning and so
this is neither this is never going to
be either/or it's got to be both and I
think technology can help to strengthen
teaching help teachers not just teach
but actually know whether their students
are learning or not the goal is not to
teach the goal is actually have students
learn to have students much more engaged
in their own learning that parents know
what's working and what's not and have
them be better partners and so I just
see tremendous upside I think there's a
huge equity play here to give students
and communities who historically have
not had the best of education
opportunities to really level the
playing field but it's also a chance to
raise the bar at the high end if you can
do both those things
push equity very very hard and raise the
bar for the country I may feel it's
early we're in our infancy you and
others to help them to leave this field
but I'm actually extraordinarily hopeful
about where this can go
ya know complete completely agree with
that I mean what we've seen at Khan
Academy is once again people a lot of
times have it that knee-jerk reaction
Ellis's technology versus physical but
it's the exact opposite a couple couple
quick examples the president I when we
made the announcement about increasing
access to broadband we went to
Mooresville North Carolina this is a
district is invested heavily in
technology over the past six seven eight
years in tough economic times no
additional money what they simply
stopped doing is buying textbooks I
continue to wonder is Ignatian why we
keep spending seven eight nine billion
dollars each year on textbooks that are
literally out of dates basically the day
you purchase them so they'd made that
shift and again veteran teachers feel
that they're teaching an entirely
different level I've been to places like
school of one in New York where you have
larger classrooms 3040 children working
in small groups teachers walking between
different groups again veteran New York
teachers initially very scared about
this think they're changing his lives in
a really important way so again early on
a lot to learn together
but I'm very very helpful not just on
the k-12 side but in higher ed with
MOOCs as well yeah no absolutely but
moving on to keep the trouble a lot of
the questions we've gotten have been
around around the Common Core in
particular
Nathan nasbe wrote you know we've
already had standards at a state level
how's the Common Core are going to be
different we have several questions
Deborah do Bartolomeo kind of wrote that
in her stay in New York there are
already having issues with graduation
rates what what does a common core gonna
do there is and I'll throw in my two
sentences you know at Khan Academy we're
very focused on intentionally creating
material for the common core the thing
that I see in it is it's much deeper and
much more rigorous and so in that world
it's it's really a higher standard than
we've had in the past so I guess those
are the two questions how will it
improve overall learning and graduation
rates and and and and is there a risk
that it's maybe too rigorous these are
great and great questions important
questions but let me be really clear one
of the things I think his his hurt
children in communities and ultimately
our country tremendously is we had 50
different states with 50 different
standards and many of which got dummy
down they got reduced to make
politicians look good we were actually
lying to Children and Families telling
them they are prepared to be successful
when frankly they weren't even close and
to me that is absolutely insidious it is
heartbreaking that's the worst thing
that can happen to a child and families
that think they're on track to be in
college and career-ready and they get to
senior year and find out they're not
even in the ball game they have no hope
of doing that and they think they're
played by all the rules and this has
happened in some places for far too long
and so the idea of having high standards
college and career-ready standards that
are internationally benchmarked so we
will no longer be lying to students and
Families is a game changer now it's
gonna take a tremendous amount of work
to help to prepare students to give
teachers the PD they need the
implementation of this is gonna be rocky
and hard and difficult but I tell you
every time you raise standards students
do better they're more engaged Sal I'll
argue the vast majority of students who
drop out don't drop out because high
schools too hard they drop out because
high school is boring
they're not connected to not engage and
your point the chance to go deeper more
critical thinking skills more analytical
skills we think is hugely important
teachers across the country have really
embraced this it is hard work if they
know they're taking on more we do a
great job supporting them but I'm so
hopeful about where this is gonna go
over the next two three four years and
if we can have the courage to stay the
course as a nation I'm will be an
entirely different place I can tell you
literally for the first time in our
country's history a child in
Massachusetts or a child in Maryland or
a child in Mississippi they're gonna be
held to the same high standards as you
know so well young people today aren't
competing for jobs in their district or
in their state in the country they're
competing for jobs with children in
India and China and Singapore in South
Korea and I'm convinced our children are
smart as talented as creative as
entrepreneurial as children anywhere in
the world we just have to level the
playing field for them we have to give
them a chance and that's what this
effort which is being led by States on a
voluntary basis that's what this is all
about and following up on that we've got
a lot of a lot of folks here who you
know with the common core also expressed
fear that this you know we there's a bit
of general trend more emphasis on
testing more emphasis on testing and the
fear is is it with the common core that
seems like it's an even larger emphasis
on standards possibly testing what's
what's your view on this balance between
the very the objective things that you
can test in a test and whether it should
be high-stakes or not for things like
teacher evaluation and the the
intangibles feels experiential learning
things like that yeah I think there's
these are really important issues that
we have to work through together but
I'll say part of what I resent is so
much about the No Child Left Behind law
and I lived on the other side of it for
7 1/2 years I led a Chicago Public
Schools we wanted Congress to fix the
broken law unfortunate Congress is
pretty dysfunctional with providing
waivers to 40 states so we're partnering
very very well directly with states
across the political spectrum who had No
Child Left Behind did I think it did
lead to an overemphasis on a test not a
proficiency cut score which i think is
you know lots of perverse incentives
there are lots of bad things for kids
and for educators what you're seeing
through the waiver process is states
moving in a very different direction
yes they're looking at growth and gain
improvements which I think should be
part of multiple measures of what you're
looking at but they're moving way beyond
a focus on test scores they're looking
at increasing graduation rates reducing
dropout rates are more high school
graduates actually going on to some form
of higher education are they doing that
not having to take remedial classes I
have to tell you so many young people
around the country 40 50 percent some
communities are taking remedial classes
again these are the graduates these ones
have made it through they're not ready
are they persevering in higher ed so
what you're seeing in terms of
accountability is moving way beyond a
focus on a test score which I think has
lots of problems looking at much more
long term outcomes and I think that's a
very very healthy thing so we want
Common Core to continue in that trend
but having states and districts and
schools look not just a third grade test
score but again are we graduating more
students are they graduating prepared to
chase their dreams again be that in the
world of higher ed or in the world of
work I'm a much more holistic sense of
accountability comprehensive absolutely
the right direction to go in states
again I think they're showing tremendous
leadership and courage and creativity in
these areas yeah absolutely
and another you know I guess an
overarching theme and we've got a lot of
a lot of tweets that kind of touch touch
on this issue is that the teachers
themselves often are feeling they're
feeling marginalized in the conversation
they're feeling that a kind of everyone
solution is sometimes to blame teachers
and you know I think what you and I
would agree that education is literally
the probably the most important
investment that we could make in society
and oftentimes it's lip service to the
importance of that and the lip service
the importance of teachers but the way
things have structured right now that
they don't get paid what a what a doctor
or a lawyer engineer gets be you know
they don't get oftentimes the same
respect that a doctor or a lawyer
engineer gets you know what can we do to
move more in that direction you know let
me say a couple things first of all
anyone who is blaming teachers is part
of the problem not part of the solution
teachers do extraordinarily hard complex
difficult work every single day
often without enough resources again I'm
in hundreds of schools each year
and teachers are working amazingly hard
obviously literally just this week you
saw in DeKalb County in Georgia teachers
and school members prevented what could
have been just a horrific massacre and
just showed tremendous tremendous
courage
I mean literal heroes profil profiles
encourage and president I talked to one
of those staff members last night
answering at haha I talked to the entire
team this morning and so teachers
routinely go way way beyond the call of
duty so what we need to do together is
to elevate and to strengthen the
teaching profession to do everything we
can to attract and retain great talent
we've put out a blueprint people can
look on our website the respect
initiative we think it's again the best
thing we can do I'll say two other
things um as a country I think we're
just this fork in the road of whether we
see education as an investment as you
and I do and I would argue the best
investment we can make or an expense and
every time I go testify before Congress
we have a set of folks who say we should
cut back on education and cut back on
headstart and on you know K to 12 and on
Pell grants and I just think that's very
very troubling and it's cutting off our
nose to spite our face again we want to
have the best educated country in the
world and we have politicians who refuse
to invest it makes no sense
am I worried desperately right now in
real time about what's going on in the
city of Philadelphia I worry about as a
school year starts those children there
who deserve the best education receiving
that inferior education because folks
refuse to invest North Carolina is a
state I worry tremendously about North
Carolina used to be sort of a national
leader in reform and so many things
teachers salaries have dropped
precipitously in North Carolina I spoke
last week with some teachers and it was
a these are fantastic teachers in North
Carolina and Salas absolutely
heartbreaking I'm you have teachers
literally who are making so little money
now that they were on food stamps
they're receiving food stamps to feed
their children I spoke to another
teacher who is giving blood who was
selling blood like twice a month to pay
the bills and again for me it just makes
no sense whatsoever so how we elevate
the profession
how we strengthen it I've already argued
very publicly that we should pay
starting teachers a heck of a lot more
money we should pay fantastic teachers
two to three times as much money it is
the best investment we can make right
now as a country in too many states and
localities folks I think don't quite
understand that and I would argue in
tough economic times education is not
something you cut back on you actually
double down your investment we have to
educate our way to a better economy do
you want more upward mobility more
social mobility the only way you do that
is to strengthen America's classrooms
and to support our nation's fantastic
teachers yeah no I agree with you I just
it's just scary I mean some of what you
just talked about it yeah and I think a
lot of I mean we definitely agree that
there has to be more investment there to
ask me ways to compensate teachers
better but at the same time you have
these budgetary pressures so I just hope
that these two things don't run into
each other with negative what I always
say says it you know these are tough
economic times and yes they're budgetary
pressures but I always say budgets
aren't numbers on a piece of paper
budgets reflect our values and the
question I always asked when you know
hold us accountable the federal level
and you see the president tried to
increase investment in every level early
childhood k12 higher ed every single
year one of the things I'm most proud of
is an additional 40 billion dollars for
Pell grants serving almost nine million
young more than nine million unfilled
Pell grants but we can't do it by
ourselves
and when states cut funding to education
but keep increasing funding for prisons
as many states do they're making a value
judgment they would prefer to lock
people up to incarcerate them to invest
them in the front end so yes we all have
in our own families in our budgets
professionally personally we all have to
make tough calls but the calls we make
the investments we make reflect our
values and I just desperately hope more
States than more communities and more
elected officials at the national level
you know in Congress House and Senate
understand that we have to invest in
education if that means we have to spend
less on other things that might be a
tough call
but is the right call to make for our
children for our families and ultimately
for our country you know and with that
you know
we should be investing in in more in
education and as we do it and we do the
best a reasonable amount already what's
your view and there's a lot of talk now
this is something that we get a lot of
questions on and we talk about a lot is
is is thinking about the structure of
education itself that you know that the
the way that we teach and right now is
really something we inherited from the
18th century Prussians where we group
kids together and we move them at a set
pace and at least to some of what you
talked about that kids get promoted
because they were in a chair for a year
and then they get to Community College
or college and they're testing in a
sixth grade math level the other side of
it is more of a competency-based model
where you know students take as long as
they need to learn something but then
they get to a very high standard and so
really that would make it possible that
someone graduates and and has to take
remedial math do you see things shifting
there that they have to shift we have to
continue to accelerate the fact that
we're still teaching with a 19th century
model makes no sense whatsoever you know
25 or 30 kids sitting in roles all
learning the same thing at the same time
same pace again it just it's like a
Neanderthal it makes no sense and so
this idea again with technology being a
great tool to empower of moving from
seat time as you said so clearly to
competency I don't want to know how long
you sat there I want to know do you know
the material do you know algebra or
biology or physics or chemistry or
whatever might be if you know it you
shouldn't have to see you shouldn't have
to sit there so we're doing everything
we can to encourage this on the you know
K to 12 side I'm on the higher ed we're
starting to do some pilot some
experimental programs with places like
the University of a southern New
Hampshire there's moving from from seat
time to master you to competency this is
absolutely where we need to go and
what's still important for me so it's
not just for the high fliers yes it's
going to benefit the high fliers I need
to be able to move much more quickly but
the average student should be able to
get the help they need that student who
takes more time it doesn't matter how
long it takes them to learn it they just
need to master that content so whether
there's more time during the school day
more time after school or at night at
home and again using technology weekends
the goal is to become comfortable and
confident with whatever the material is
that whatever your third grade 5th grade
AP Physics and so this for me is a
game-changer
for kids it's absolutely the right thing
to do and time should be variable not
time should not be the constant the
constant should be our students having
opportunities to learn to master the
material to be engaged in their own
learning so again there's some really
creative innovative things starting to
happen but part of I think our role is
to take these these areas of innovations
these pockets of excellence and try and
share these best practices and actually
take them to scale to make this the norm
rather than the exception yeah and I
mean there's just too undone underlined
that I mean a lot of times what we see
is yes you let students go at their own
pace and the assumption is some kids are
just going to take longer and fall
further and further behind but we're
seeing over and over again a few let
students put their own pace a lot of
times that students if you thought was a
little bit slower they're taking their
time really filling in their gaps they
end up becoming the best students in the
class six months later I think and the
more you can articulate those findings
and demonstrate them are so important
far too many adults underestimate what
students can do and yes we know students
need helping you support them but I get
our biggest problem I think in this
country is not that we're pushing kids
too hard is that we're not encourage
them enough we're not giving them enough
opportunities to learn and do more
whenever you raise damage maybe give
opportunities you don't have more
dropouts you have more graduates the
problem I'm guarantee you has always
been that we dummy things down for kids
and they feel that they know it they
sense it they know that they think that
we're not stares about their education
and they become disengaged they back out
and we give them a chance to fly to
learn to empower them you see
extraordinary things happen again not
just for those at the top but those who
we thought may have been struggling let
them find their passion let them find
their interest and they'll go to the
moon with that we have to create those
opportunities and another I guess just
overarching theme it's a long the same
idea of us kind of going with a legacy
system that we've had you know since
Horace Mann brought us the Prussian
system in the mid 19th century is not
only the system itself kind of seat time
versus competency but what is actually
covered you know there's something I've
written about a lot of people know is it
you know this is this decision to do
algebra in ninth grade out you know
geometry and trigonometry calculus and
physics in senior year and all of that
that was decided essentially by
ten men about 120 years ago and so you
know one question I get I just even have
myself you know I love calculus I made
400 videos online
I love the subject I need to watch your
videos I'm you get exciting stuff but
I'm the one thing I wonder is something
like statistics is far more applicable
and pretty much any field you go into
but that's usually reserved for kind of
an elective course in college and it is
it for things like law is you only get
frankly if you go to law school you
don't even get it at an undergraduate
level is there is there some movement to
try to make this more part of the core
curriculum so I always talked about a
well-rounded world-class education and
so as all the things you mentioned it's
computer science which obviously didn't
exist as hundred years of class I don't
want to mention that people computer
science there are a lot of great jobs in
computer science that are going unfilled
today you know Cody we have here I would
add to that foreign languages I would
add to that financial literacy I would
add to that physical education and
recess health and so these are things
that generally you see in the in the
elite private schools they are just sort
of part of the core but somehow in
public education again often due to
underfunding lack of investment all
those things kind of get stripped away
and again I worry about you know
generally but very specifically right
now about places like Philadelphia and
North Carolina but I think it really is
sort of a time of crisis and when you
take away those kinds of opportunities
our children should be growing up
bilingual and trilingual they have to be
financially literate they have to have
the computer science and other things
that has to be part of the core
curriculum so yes the basic reading and
math are fundamental and foundational
but that's a starting point not an
ending point and again if we're serious
about keeping kids in school reducing
dropout rates they're devastatingly high
it's all of those things that I would
add is more it's all the
extracurriculars it's banned it's art
it's music it's chess it's sports it's
academic decathlon it's yearbook it's
theaters Model UN that all has to be the
norm as well and again when we walk away
from that we really really hurt our
children you know I even go a little
further I actually think a lot of that
stuff I mean
I think about my own education a lot of
my real memories from middle school in
high school I felt I learned the most
were some of the things you just listed
and and it almost feels like we there's
not tree to rethink in these
extracurriculars become the curricular
and that all the core skills are ways to
support that but but I hundred percent
100% agree with that you know with all
of these you know we've just talked
about a bunch of really I think powerful
ideas and things that are the correct
direction it but where do you see the
federal government in this is you know
as the Secretary of Education obviously
education is mainly executed on by the
states
how do you how do you all try to
influence what happens in the right
direction so so again our goal is to
lead the world in college graduation
rates that's the North Star that's what
the president has challenged us to do on
one generation ago we led the world we a
flatline we've stagnated about a dozen
other countries that passed us by and I
think we're paying a real price for that
as a nation so for me it's about
investing into every level its
increasing access to early childhood
education you know I haven't talked
about that this morning that's arguably
the most important investment we can
make is to get our babies off to a good
start let them enter kindergarten ready
to be successful we have to continue to
improve K to 12 driver form increased
graduation rates reduce dropout rates
make sure our high school graduates are
truly college and career ready and again
the big push are making now is it some
form of higher ed four-year universities
two-year community colleges trade
technical vocational training that has
to be the goal for every single young
person today and so how we share best
practices how we continue to encourage
investment how we reward innovation and
courage how we think about this
comprehensively again really birth
through age year whatever 22 23 24 and
even beyond adult learners coming back
Community College doing a great job
there this for me is we're fighting for
our country here we're fighting for our
families we want to provide as much
leadership as we can and drive this
agenda but again we need great
partnership at the state and local level
as well right and it sounds like the way
that you'll execute obviously you'll
have a soapbox if you will people will
listen based on you can set the
direction and on top of that the
Department of Education goes out there
and and really kind of rewards districts
in States
that if y'all feel it moving in the
right direction and we try to invest so
historically our department didn't
invest in early childhood education we
thought that was a problem with
Congress's bipartisan support we've
invested about six hundred million
dollars to increase early childhood
opportunities and states across the
country that's a big deal we would like
to invest dramatically more we want to
make sure that every child has access
there which we've saved a couple hundred
thousand teacher jobs and tough economic
times
we're also driving reform K to twelve
and then I said on the higher ed side
one of things I'm most proud of was a 40
billion dollar increase in Pell grants
without going back to taxpayers were
nickel we simply stopped subsidizing
banks put all that money into Pell
grants that was wildly controversial
here in Washington we've got his common
sense we've gone from about 6 million
power recipients to nine point six
million but to be really clear as we
sorted where we started the conversation
I'm very concerned that college is
becoming unaffordable not just in
disadvantaged communities but for the
middle class and so I'm proud of what
we've done
this is absolutely unfinished business
and we have to push very very hard so
that families have the security of
knowing if theirs if their children work
hard they will have the chance to pursue
higher ed once they graduate from high
school and and you did touch on the
early learning which is and I have a
four-year-old and a two-year-old and
they're in preschool now and I and I
personally as a parent have seen the
value of what's done for them you know
they were a few years before they go
into the formal system why do you think
that hasn't been more universal in a
Florida famously has early childhood and
that you know it's kind of a very
bipartisan way under under Governor Jeb
Bush what why don't we see that more on
a nationwide basis I'll tell you why
because two and three and four-year-olds
your children don't vote right I'm
obvious they don't have packs and I
think too many politicians are wired to
think about their next election or just
the next new cycle in early childhood
education is the ultimate in long term
investments and the dividends we often
don't see for a decade or two or three
or four but folks who are a lot smarter
than me like James Heckman the Nobel
prize-winning economist at the
University of kaga was talked about a
seven to one return on investment that
every dollar we put in early childhood
we as a country get back seven dollars
less teenage pregnancy less crime less
in car
Jason more high school graduates more
folks going to college more folks going
into the workforce paying taxes being
productive citizens but it's a long-term
play so the president has put on the
table a 75 billion dollar proposal to
dramatically expand access to
high-quality early learning
opportunities around the country what's
so interesting sales at the state level
this has absolutely become a bipartisan
issue and you see great leadership by
Republican and Democratic governors who
in tough economic times are choosing to
invest they are valuing this quite
frankly our struggle now is to get more
of our Republican friends here in
Washington in the House and Senate to
agree this is the right long-term
investment I'm working very hard behind
the scenes I'm hopeful in the
not-too-distant future they will start
to see a couple Republicans join with us
to say this is the right thing for our
children for strengthens families and
ultimately for our country right all
right and going to the other end of the
spectrum when we talk about college and
graduation resistors where we started
our conversation the only thing that I
hear a lot about is you know I hear this
even from you know sometimes but I talk
to be partnered with schools and like
hey we a lot of our kids go to college
then people are well they should be
graduating from college and and we've
talked about that today but it seems
like even that really isn't the real end
goal the real end goal is are they being
productive and happy citizens and is
some of what you're talking about
also along that dimension it's not just
because obviously a college can graduate
everyone if it wants to it can pick in
lower standards it's kind of what we
talked about the state level but their
hands how many just make sure that it
doesn't happen just kind of window
dressing yeah well we have to be very
thoughtful comprehensive we're going to
go out and travel the country and talk
to college presidents and faculty
members again as students and you know
students themselves and parents and
employers sort of get a sense of this
but I think your your bigger thing
anytime we're dumbing down standards
whether it's higher ed or K to 12 or a
child anytime we EE down standards we're
just doing a great disservice to the
folks we claim we're serving so that's a
non-starter to begin with how you make
sure you have a high bar how you make
sure students are engaged civically sort
of in a participant participatory
democracy how they're you're thinking
about giving back to the community what
they're doing after college graduation
rates yes we need more stem majors yes
we need more computer science I was a
very happy sociology major
and we want to again just let people
pursue their dreams whatever it might be
liberal arts doesn't matter but we want
them being in a position to be
successful once they graduate and that
for me is what we have to be looking at
so long term and three it's not about
salaries it's not about whatever you
know obviously folks are going to
education don't do that to make a
million dollars they do it to make a
difference but I want them going to
education prepared to be a great
educator and if they can do that and be
successful then I feel good about that
if folks are unprepared for the world of
work whatever their dreams are that's
when we have to challenge the status quo
agree and I mean we have time really
just for one final question so I'll make
it a big picture question and you know
we're talking a lot of things are a lot
of exciting things going on there's
technology there's access where do you
think this is going to go and you know
if we just dream a little bit if we if
we look at the system 10 years from now
20 years from now is it going to look
like the system we have now quite
frankly I hope it looks very different
from the system today that we have today
because I just think we're not doing
enough quite frankly as a nation so my
hope not even 10 years out but five
years out I'm inpatient here I don't
want to wait I would love to see twice
as many children have access to
high-quality pre-k so dramatically
expand access there I would like to see
almost no classrooms of kissin and rows
of 25 and 30 and I want to see students
having a chance to learn individually
and worked in small groups again using
technology company and moving from seat
time to competency we that has to happen
I want to see graduation rates there are
actually two three decade high which is
encouraging we still have a long way to
go
graduation has to be the bare minimum if
you drop out of high school today you're
basically condemned to poverty and
social failure so we have to get those
dropout rates down to zero as fast as we
can and then ultimately again high
school graduates have to be college and
career-ready
but college has to be much more
accessible and affordable and so if we
can really drive down the cost of
college not just a you know a couple
percent but significantly so that that
dream that aspiration becomes a reality
families have that security um it is
clearly an ambitious agenda but I
frankly think we have to
on all those fronts simultaneously and
move as fast as we can and move again
regardless of politics or ideology I
could care less and that we just want to
help our country we want to help our
young people who want strengthen our
families we should be able to work
together on this um this is our national
mission well know that that was a
completely agree and Thank You secretary
Duncan this was a real honor to be able
to chat with you this morning did a
great job you can be the next Oprah when
you're done with thanks for the
opportunity and thanks again your
tremendous leadership I'm a big fan
thank you